est-ce que vous avez déjà ressenti après
la mort d'une personne que vous aimiez
qu'il ya moyen d'entrer en contact avec
elle tu veux parler un débit ouais c'est
ici que des billets morte je pense pas
que ce soit une bonne idée
c'est un ami sincère que nous nous
présentons esprit de l'au-delà en ces
lieux nous tarde beaucoup si tu peux
entendre ce que tu manques
ouais c'est bon qu'il a fait bouger là
s'arrête c'est pas moi qui les pousse et
ça donne elle a mis sa fiche la trouille
ça suffit maintenant on arrête
allez à tout prix que je fais mais ça
débile a trouvé la planche chez elle et
elle a réveillé une force cette chose
note
il ya quelqu'un il s'occupera de chacun
d'entre nous à qui le tour
vous devez rompre la connexion oui vous
retrouvera il va falloir et jouer de
nouveau c'est un ami sincère que nous
nous présentons et puis le lot de la
cellule esprit es tu là
c'est pas réel ok c'est juste